it's a big day for Democrats who have
been raving about how great sanctuary
cities are for years sanctuary policies
actually make cities safer to be clear
about what Chicago is it always will be
a sanctuary city together let us build a
house stronger than the coming storms
yet open to the world the house that
provides shelter to all who need it and
sanctuary to all who seek it president
Trump's ready to give these liberals
exactly what they've always wanted by
saying he may dump illegal immigrants in
their cities we could fix that in so
fast
if the Democrats would agree but if they
don't agree we might as well do what
they always say they want we'll bring
them to sanctuary city areas and let
that particular area take care of it
whether it's a state or whatever it
might be California certainly is always
saying oh we want more people and they
want more people in their sanctuary
cities well we'll give them more people
we can give them a lot we can give them
an unlimited supply and let's see if
they're so happy Nancy Pelosi's home
district in San Francisco is reportedly
one of the areas that the White House
discussed but for some reason the House
Speaker is upset about it I don't know
anything about it but again it sent just
another notion that is unworthy of the
presidency of the United States and
disrespectful the challenges that we
face as a country as a people to address
who we are a nation of immigrants all
right this idea is actually going to
happen but it does serve the purpose of
illustrating the hypocrisy from some of
the Democrats in this country who say
yeah bring them in provide sanctuary
city just not in my city let me start by
agreeing that I think that a lot of what
the president is saying is born of
frustration because of the lack of
cooperation by the Democrats on the
border they are doing nothing to help
other than making things more difficult
but this is a stunt you're not gonna
take this is it also illegal I'm telling
you that it is illegal because that's
gambling that you cannot use people as
props to do it make a political point
we've been doing it for 40 years this is
the road from the border to wherever the
illegal immigrants are being taken will
be lined with lawsuits I guarantee it
okay Emily I think the restriction is
financial you can't just spend it so it
costs a lot of money to transport people
all the way from the border to San
Francisco yes one of the limitations on
it would be budgetary in terms of
whether it's considered legal I want to
point out that I I just think the
biggest issue to me is that the
Democrats aren't listening to local law
enforcement and there aren't they are
not listening to regular people it's
such a top-down discussion and that is
why there's such friction at the local
community level that people are upset
about you guys remember in February when
the women Bambi Larson was like brutally
murdered by a 6-time civil detainer
request illegal immigrant he had a
history of violent felonies etc it was
you know it's kind of one of those token
cases of which unfortunately there are a
lot
guess what happened on Tuesday the Santa
Clara County Administration voted
overwhelmingly to soften the sanctuary
policy because the point is those
policies harm communities in multiple
ways including the immigrant community
because it doesn't provide the clarity
that they can use to understand how and
when they can immigrant immigrate
legally and so in Santa Clara County
they're basically there they're voting
to soften it and as they say the
immigration laws there are dysfunctional
everyone is confused and as I always say
whose job is it then to clarify get to
it legislators instead of squawking
about it go do your job and clarify the
policy and then we can all survive I
this headline from the Washington Post
white house want wanted border detainees
released in sanctuary cities to target
Trump foes so even the media is
portraying the very policies that they
claim to love as punishment I mean if
you're gonna I mean they're actually mad
at Trump for giving them what they asked
for so it let's say it's a stunt let's
say it's a bad idea the fact is if you
don't like having these released illegal
immigrants there you have to explain why
because this is your policy you have
created this this problem so if you if
it pollutes
thinks it's a stunt if you don't don't
don't say it's illegal say why don't you
want them that's a great thing if you're
a reporter in Washington Pelosi gives
her thursday press conference next week
she's gonna have a lot to answer for
there's gonna be lots of things a couple
things first of all I don't think that
this policy if it emphasises don't let's
say it's implemented I don't think it
stops the flow of migrants coming to the
border no guys they're like oh well then
maybe we get to address the real
problems president says they're shootin
the major problem is the migrant crisis
at the border right we're being
overwhelmed we don't have enough
resources all of it so that's that's one
thing the other thing it reminds me of
Bridgegate using the your political
levers in order to attack your political
enemies and again his I don't think that
the president's base needs firing up I
get that it's it's a great point it's
like it does like plays mind games with
the Democrats like oh really well then
what about you what are you going to do
the other thing I would say is if the
administration who denied this up until
two hours before the president tweeted
it and say it was going to happen
don't brainstorm in emails brainstorm in
person not in emails I just I just think
I don't think you can compare it to
Bridgegate I think that it was probably
an idea that they put forth but you're
in it I do think it does make progress
because you're gonna force the Democrats
to either embrace or deviate from a
policy that they believe hypothetically
Democrats to cooperate with its
president called I love the president
but he's tempestuous and he's
thin-skinned he should call up Chuck
Schumer sound familiar call him up and
say hey listen dude let's do something
before we're really in the heat of the
presidential election we've got a
million people coming across the
southern border there is the crisis of
which useful but you okay to that point
we have had two parties that haven't
solved this problem because they never
wanted to this is the breathe in and
Trump being essentially a political
let's face it he was a Democrat for a
law
tonight he's a Republican because it
made sense he is the first person really
to say let's try to solve it for good
he's being the adult in the room that's
fair I think that there are definitely I
would say look I work for George W Bush
he wanted to solve that problem there
the deal that was on the table is the
one that is probably going to be the one
that is going to be solidified the
people on the extremes right and left
are the ones that don't want to deal and
that's what rules people apart I think
President Trump could make this deal
tomorrow that's why George Bush got 44%
of the Latino vote but that wasn't the
that wasn't the reason he wanted to do
it you wanted that border security but
yeah